Bonsoir à tous, bienvenue
à cette émission spéciale.
C'est une situation jamais
vue dans l'histoire récente.
- On est dans une crise qui va
durer des mois.
- On est clairs qu'on brime un
peu les droits individuels, mais
c'est pour le bien collectif.
- Il faut se préparer.
- Porter une attention spéciale
aux personnes vulnérables.
- C'est la confiance dans la
science. C'est d'écouter celles
et ceux qui savent.
- Concernant l'avenir, on est en
train chaque heure de regarder
la situation.
- Et je suis convaincu qu'on est
capable tous ensemble de passer
aux travers de cette épreuve.
Bonsoir à tous, bienvenue
à cette émission spéciale.
Des mesures draconniennes
sont mises en place. Et avec
cet appel à la prudence,
aussi un appel au calme
et à la solidarité.
Au cours des deux prochaines
heures, nous ferons le bilan
de ce que vous devez savoir,
de ce que l'on vit,
de ce qui nous attend.
Nos experts répondront aussi
à certaines de vos questions.
À mes côtés, le Dr Karl Weiss,
microbiologiste-infectiologue,
la Dre Christine Grou,
présidente de l'Ordre des
psychologues du Québec,
la Dre Cécile Tremblay,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
et le Dr Horacio Arruda,
directeur national de
la Santé publique du Québec.
Bonsoir à vous quatre.
Et aussi, Julie Émond.
Parce que les téléspectateurs
vont nous poser des questions.
- On a reçu plusieurs questions
cette semaine. On fait appel à
vous pour nous envoyer vos
questions et vos commentaires et
vos réactions tout au long de
l'émission. Vous pouvez le faire
sur Twitter ou nous écrire par
courriel ou encore sur notre
page Facebook de Radio-Canada
info. On fait un état des lieux
où on se trouve actuellement à
l'échelle pancanadienne.
Commençons par ce qui se passe
dans l'est dans les provinces
dans l'Atlantique, le Nouveau-
Brunswick a déclaré un premier
cas aujourd'hui.
Vous dire que Nouveau-Brunswick.
La mesure qu'on a annoncé ce
qu'on suspend jusqu'à nouvel
ordre les procès devant jury,
première initiative de ce côté.
Au Québec on a très cas
confirmés et aucun cas probable.
Il y a eu beaucoup d'annonce de
ce côté. La ville de Montréal a
annoncé la fermeture de nombreux
lieux publics et on pense à des
arénas, les salles de
spectacles, des lieux comme le
planétarium et la biosphère et
j'en passe. Pas de fermeture sur
le métro, mais on surveille la
situation de près. Plutôt
aujourd'hui, il y a eu de
nombreux point de presse et de
nombreuses questions adressées à
nos élus. Il annonçait des
mesures particulières. C'est une
recommandation, pour tous les
employés de l'État qui travaille
comme fonctionnaire ou qui sont
dans des milieux de garde ou des
écoles ou dans la santé, la
directive est obligatoire.
Québec recommande en terminant
d'annuler tout avènement qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire.
Je termine avec les autres
provinces. En Ontario on a
présentement 64 confirmés mais
il y en a plus de 540 en cours
d'analyse. Toute une épidémie en
Ontario et c'est pourquoi on
annonce la fermeture de toutes
les écoles publiques jusqu'au 5
avril prochain. On n'y va de
mesures préventives. Un bébé de
moins d'un an qui a été eu un
contact étroit avec un patient
contaminé. Au Manitoba et en
Saskatchewan on a un cas dans
chacun des provinces. On a 23
cas en Alberta.
La Colombie-Britannique on
Hassett nouveaux cas divulgués
dans la dernière heure.
On n'en a maintenant 53
- Merci.
Je commence avec vous Docteur,
beaucoup d'annonces sur les
mesures particulières du Québec
notamment à l'endroit de
l'interdiction d'avoir des
rassemblements de plus de 250
personnes ou encore entendre des
voyageurs.
- C'est l'épidémiologie mondiale
parce que les objectifs et vous
voyez ce qui en Italie un
système de santé de bonne
qualité qui est surchargée
actuellement parce que à une
augmentation rapide du nombre de
cas. L'OMS recommande notamment
et les mesures de santé publics
classiques sont importantes à
implanter juste avant qu'on perd
le contrôle ou concentré comme
contaminé. Ici au Québec, on a
des cas qui viennent d'Italie ou
de France et d'Europe et on a un
autre profil parce que c'est
associé au voyageur qui
atterrisse à certains
territoires et dans ce contexte,
et dans le contexte où c'est
partout et les chiffres ne sont
pas toujours fiables ont parce
que le voyage et des mesures
autour de voyages sont majeures
pour diminuer le bombardement du
virus et de mesure ici au Québec
pour éviter la transmission
éventuellement des mesures et
décider aujourd'hui à jour et
s'ajuster au jour le jour et
c'est pour cela que avoir des
point de presse quotidiens et
fait partie des questions et des
habitudes et je tiens à vous
dire que c'est à la fois nos
cliniciens qui vont être pris
avec le traitement des patients,
mais à la fois les entreprises
et tout le Québec tous les
citoyens doivent poser des
gestes particulièrement aussi
pour protéger nos plus
vulnérables et nos plus âgées.
Il faut se laver les mains aussi
il faut aplatir la courbe.
- La courbe elle s'en vient.
Vous avez dit aujourd'hui c'est
de dire qu'on en a encore pour
un bon bout de temps.
- Ça va partir comme cela et on
a une population qui est vierge
au virus et vous voyez la courbe
rouge, c'est si on pousse.
Si on se retrouve dans la copro,
c'est la Cavallero beaucoup de
quand même temps et c'est là que
le système est problématique.
Ça va être important d'avoir
assez de soins intensifs et si
on est capable et on va
s'ajuster à l'épidémiologie,
mais même si on prend des
mesures pour s'ajuster et fermer
des affaires moins courantes, on
est mieux d'étaler la courbe et
d'aller vers l'autre courbe avec
les autres couleurs de telle
sorte à ce moment, on n'a pas ce
pic et la pression sur le
système de soins est moins
grande parce qu'il y a également
le personnel qui doit être
présent. C'est pour cela et
l'OMS et de façon classique, ces
mesures qui empêchent la
transmission de la communauté
moi on a des gens qui font la
maladie, moins on va voir des
gens qui vont y aller parce
qu'il faut essayer d'essayer
chacun des cas génère moins de
cas par des interventions de
cette nature d'isolement et des
interventions questions des
mentales entreprenants certains
événements et surtout pas
visiter les personnes âgées qui
sont à plus haut risque.
- On attend peut-être jusqu'à 70
% de la population. Être
atteinte. Qu'est-ce ça veut
dire. Est-ce que ça génère une
grande inquiétude ou c'est une
invitation à la prudence?
- Il faut comprendre que les
chiffres de 30 à 70 % on a un
début d'épidémie et il y a
plusieurs données il va y avoir
des études plus tard pour mieux
documenter ce sont des
estimations. C'est sûr que plus
il y a de cas en même temps,
plus de dit qu'une préparation
de ce cela se rende à l'hôpital.
La vérité probablement est entre
les deux, mais je pense que
c'est clair de toute façon il
faut se préparer.
- Est-ce que vous anticipez des
mesures comme en Italie ou à New
York.
- Ça dépend comment le virus va
se comporter. Son ADK partout au
Québec, on ne peut pas confiner
le Québec. Sa ça passe dans les
écoles ou ailleurs, de fermes sa
possible et des ondes entre
guillemets de quarantaine
pourraient être possibles.
- On a des questions du public.
Qu'est-ce qui a guidé le choix
de 250 personnes.
- Il n'y a pas d'études ou de
donnée probante qui va dire que
c'était chez et ce n'est pas
parce que non un événement à 225
on ne peut pas l'une annuler. Ça
été un guide pour les gros
événements.
- Et pour les écoles, il y a des
écoles qui vont être fermées
dans le pays il y a des écoles
publiques on ne sait rien
encore, il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétude. Ce sera une étape
importante fermeture des écoles.
Accès parti des scénarios?
- Il va y avoir des point de
presse chaque jour il pourrait y
avoir des annonces à chaque jour
par rapport à ces événements..
L'Ontario l'a fait parce que
c'est la semaine de relâche,
mais on regarde cela.
- Une question sur ce qui se
passe ailleurs au Canada, on a
une épidémiologie particulière.
Il y a des foyers de
contamination un peu partout.
Est-ce que ce qui se passe
ailleurs vous inquiète quant aux
répercussions qui après avoir
ici.
- Les voyages en Asie ont eu
plus d'impact en Colombie-
Britannique ici.
- Pour les citoyens qui
n'appartiennent pas à ces
réseaux, c'est une
recommandation.
- Il faut qu'il sache qu'on va
la recommander au retour d'être
14 jours en isolement
volontaire.
- On apprenait que les services
frontaliers resteraient les
mesures d'accueil et pour
l'Italie et l'Iran alors que les
Canada...
- on demande plusieurs choses à
Ottawa, une plus grande présence
pour visualiser à l'arrivée
parce que il y a des discussions
qui vont y avoir lieu. On
demande l'intervention plus
spécifique de l'information
donnée sur place comme telle
pour plusieurs types de
voyageurs pour ne pas, comme je
vous dis nos cas sont pas des
cas qui arrive de ces pays.
L'augmentation des mesures
visibles qui vont être faites
pour que les patients soient
informés de la situation pour ne
pas qu'ils passent à travers les
filets.
- Merci. Réaction de votre part.
On a appris qu'en Ontario en
Colombie-Britannique on parle
d'enfants qui ont touché. On
dirait que les enfants étaient à
l'abri.
- Les enfants peuvent être
infectés et c'est juste qu'il ne
développe pas une maladie sévère
très peu de symptômes, il n'y a
pas de cas de mortalité chez les
enfants en bas de 15 ans. Il ne
rend pas une maladie sévère, ça
va pas et qui ne peuvent pas
être infecté et être des
vecteurs de transmission. On ne
sait pas encore à quel niveau
les enfants infectés excrètent
du virus est habituellement ce
que les petits-enfants ce sont
des des grands porteurs. Même
s'ils ne sont pas très malades,
il pourrait essaimer la maladie
et l'amener à la grand-maman ou
leur grand-papa et causer des
problèmes plus importants à des
populations vulnérables. C'est
quelque chose surveiller, mais
il faut pas parce que les
enfants ne peuvent pas
l'attraper.
- Et vous Docteur Weiss?
- Je pense qu'il y a deux choses
dedans. Il y a l'aspect de la
maladie infectieuse. On parle de
virus nouveau dans une
population qui n'a pas été
touchée. La situation semble
faire ce sont des mesures de
confinement et c'est ce qu'on a
fait. C'est l'aspect maladie
infectieuse quifonctionne. La
seule façon dont la Chine
réussit à contrôler les cas,
sans mettra des mesures
pareilles. Après ça, il y a
l'aspect et ce que l'on vit dans
une société où se permettre ce
genre de mesures ça peut
paraître énorme, mais c'est
courageux de la part du premier
ministre d'avoir mis ce genre de
choses ce n'est pas une décision
qui est facile pour la
population générale. Ça fait
plusieurs semaines qu'on dit et
vous savez que toutes les
mesures comme actuellement il
faut les préparer plusieurs
semaines à l'avance. Ça fait
longtemps qu'on va devoir
augmenter au Québec notre
capacité de faire des tests
c'est quelque chose qu'on
demandait depuis très longtemps
et qui est important est la
capacité de dépister pour que le
Docteur de la Santé publique
peut aller chercher où sont les
foyers, il faut qu'on puisse
identifier qui sont malades et
un ensemble de mesures très
importante et couplé aux mesures
qui vient d'être mises en places
qui sont de bonne mesure. On
peut se poser comme question
c'est alors qu'on empoche les
Québécois de sortir, pourquoi
est-ce qu'on laisse encore tout
le monde entré.
- La question revient.
- Je suis un clinicien et ce qui
est important sur
l'épidémiologie du Québec c'est
qu'on a eu des gens qui venaient
d'un peu partout et sur tournée
des surprises. Les gens qui ont
fini avoir parlé le 19 et on a
beaucoup de coqs sont
originaires d'Europe beaucoup
plus qu'ailleurs son ADK qui
continue de s'accumuler et ça
veut dire que c'est une
épidémiologie très changeante on
doit s'habituer rapidement. Ça
veut dire que le voyage ça
devient finalement peu important
et qu'il va falloir dépister
beaucoup alors être capable de
tester les gens. Ce sont les
deux points importants.
- On a plusieurs questions là-
dessus. Si on s'inspire de
l'expérience américaine, c'est
pas grand-chose. Et vous Madame
Grou?
- C'est évident quand il menace
comme cela, ça va augmenter
l'anxiété chez les gens et si la
population générale est
particulièrement chez les gens
qui ont déjà une vulnérabilité
ou qui sont des gens anxieux.
Cela dit, l'anxiété un réaction
normale et ce qui nous permet
d'être dirigeant et de nous
protéger. Quand elle est
nouvelle et l'imprévisible à des
situations ambiguës, et qu'on
n'a pas de contrôle sur la
situation. Quand on a tous ces
éléments les gens deviennent
plus anxieux et c'est pas tant
l'anxiété qui est problématique
c'est normale, c'est un
phénomène normal devant une
situation comme cela, c'est
quand elle devient démesurée
qu'elle devient mauvaise
conseillère.
- Quel conseil vous pouvait
donner? On sait pas si vous avez
une ligne d'écoute et qui ont
besoin d'être rassuré, cette
émission spéciale se poursuit au
retour avec mes invités et
surtout avec vos questions qui
sont pertinentes et nombreuses.
Le premier ministre ontarien à
la veille de la semaine de
relâche en Ontario,
est-ce que tous les ontariens
vont venir au Québec?
La ministre de la santé dit de
rester au Canada et de ne pas
aller à l'extérieur. Cette
question de propagation du
virus. Il y a une question de
Janine Dallaire qui dit ceci :
Parce qu'on ne sait pas, parfois
elles sont asymptomatiques.
Alors on revient la question.
- C'est une très bonne question.
Ça amène des éléments peut-être
d'incohérence dans l'approche,
si on peut le dire comme ça.
Mais fermer une frontière à la
visite, ça a aussi d'autres
conséquences qui ne sont pas
nécessairement pour la santé.
C'est d'évaluer en fonction du
risque. Je ne peux pas vous dire
si ce ne sera pas une mesure qui
ne sera pas prise.
Ça va être évalué au jour le
jour. Actuellement on a voulu se
concentrer sur le citoyen
québécois parce qu'on ne veut
pas... lui va revenir et va
rester ici et va pouvoir le
transmettre. Mais c'est sûr que
je ne peux pas vous dire qu'il
n'y a aucune personne de
l'extérieur qui viendrait ici
qui ne pourrait pas être malade.
Ils sont malades et ne prendront
pas l'avion parce qu'en théorie
ne sont pas supposés prendre
l'avion. En théorie.
Mais s'ils sont rendus ici
et qui développent des
symptômes, il va peut-être
falloir qu'on leur donne des
consignes de consulter pour ne
pas transmettre la maladie
partout. Mais fermer la
frontière ou les vols ce sont
des décisions qui ne sont pas
prises éléments à des
perspectives de santé public
mais ce n'est pas exclu.
- Ça dépend d'Ottawa.
- Effectivement. Ce sont des
vols internationaux.
- La majorité des patients que
j'ai vu malade avais pris des
vols malades. Personne ne leur a
demandé des questions. Ils sont
passés un peu comme dans une
passoire. À peu près tous les
cas qui ont été répertoriés au
Québec sont des cas qui sont
arrivés malades ou quasiment
malades dans les jours qui ont
suivi. Beaucoup ont été malades
pendant leur vol. C'est clair
qu'actuellement, le système
permet à ces gens de rentrer.
Mais donc des chevaux de Troie à
l'intérieur du système.
Le problème pour arrêter et
fermer les frontières c'est une
question économique.
C'est pour ça que les
gouvernements ont très peur. Ils
ont peur d'entraîner des
cascades et de dire : à partir
du moment je fermais les
frontières il y a tout un impact
d'économie et de perte de
revenus. Il cherche un équilibre
entre les deux.
Mais dans ce genre de situation
on ne peut pas prendre des demi-
mesures. À un moment donné il
faudra trancher quelque part.
Il y a beaucoup de pays qui
impose à tous les gens qui
arrivent un isolement.
Il va falloir faire attention
aussi parce qu'à un moment donné
si on ne contrôle pas notre
épidémiologie au Canada on
pourrait se faire isoler comme
canadien quand on va ailleurs et
on aura aucun contrôle là-dessus
parce que ce sont les autres
pays qui vont dire : comme vous
venez du Canada désolé vous êtes
en isolement.
- Une question de Jean-Guy
Dalpé. On me glisse à l'oreille
le premier ministre canadien
s'entretient avec le président
américain Donald Trump qui,
sans consultation des pays
alliés a annoncé hier les
interdictions de vol en
provenance d'Europe.
Sauf le Royaume-Uni qui est
sorti de l'Europe.
Mais ça a posé... causer tout un
choc. Même Canada. Puisqu'on se
dit : les voyageurs vont venir
au Canada pour ensuite aller
aux États-Unis.
On sent encore cette hésitation
du côté d'Ottawa notamment pour
des raisons économiques. Mais ce
n'est pas si simple que ça.
- Ce n'est pas si simple. Il y a
des raisons économiques
importantes mais aussi des
raisons de famille qui vont se
visiter à droite et à gauche. Ça
a des conséquences de fermer les
frontières. Aussi, une grande
conséquence envisagée, c'est si
on veut être conséquent et on
décide de fermer les frontières
de l'Europe, il faut le faire
avec les États-Unis parce que le
risque est de plus en plus grand
que l'écart vient des États-
Unis. Alors fermer la frontière
Canado-américaine, bonne chance,
je ne sais pas comment fait ça
parce qu'elle est immense.
Comment fait en sorte que ce
soit respecté. C'est ce genre de
discussion qu'il faut avoir.
La question aussi se porte : où
mettons nos ressources?
On va mettre énormément de
ressources afin de respecter une
telle règle, fermeture de la
frontière ou on met nos
ressources ailleurs pour
empêcher la propagation des cas
localement Canada. Donc, ce
n'est pas quelque chose de
simple. Il faut être sûr que la
mesure que l'on prend et la
mesure appropriée à la situation
que l'on vit présentement.
- Hier vous étiez très critique
de la décision de Donald Trump
de fermer unilatéralement la
frontière parce que ce n'était
pas reconnaître le vrai problème
aux États-Unis.
- Présentement aux États-Unis,
ils ont des gars qui arrivent de
l'étranger, mais leur grand
problème qui ne sont pas
capables de contrister la
transmission communautaire. Il y
a des éclosions dans plusieurs
régions des États-Unis. Ils ne
sont pas capables de le
contrôler parce qu'ils n'ont pas
prient les mesures d'avance. Il
n'avait pas la capacité de
tester. Ils ne sont pas capables
d'identifier les cas.
Alors ça se propage dans
certains endroits comme une
traînée de poudre. La mesure
affaire, est-ce que c'était de
fermer les frontières avec
l'Europe? Je pourrais me
questionner là-dessus d'autant
plus qu'avec le langage utilisé
qui avait une composante de
"virus étranger" et là virus
"chinois", est-ce qu'il y a plus
de politique de vraies
préoccupations de santé
publique?
-0 une autre question :
Parce que la mise en isolement,
ça commence aujourd'hui. Le
retour d'aujourd'hui.
D'accord.
- Par contre si la personne a
des préoccupations parce qu'elle
ne veut pas contaminer sa
conjointe, il pourrait, à
l'intérieur de sa maison, avoir
une distanciation.
Éviter les contacts rapprochés.
Mais très important surtout :
dès qu'il commence à sentir les
premiers symptômes de appelé
pour avoir un test.
- Et ses symptômes sont?
- Fièvre, toux, douleurs
thoraciques ou difficultés
respiratoires. Ça commence comme
un rhume mais avec de la fièvre,
des douleurs un peu partout.
Ce que je veux vous dire dans le
fond ce qu'il peut prendre une
distance avec son épouse. Ce
n'est pas agréable, je ne suis
pas dans sa maison, je ne peux
pas voir. La conjointe était pas
là.
- La plus compliquée, la
personne nous envoie une
question anonyme. "Une amie
revient de Cuba avec sa famille
son conjoint travaille pour un
ministère. Il sera sûrement en
quarantaine. Mon ami en
entreprise privée doit-t-elle se
mettre en quarantaine. Qu'en
est-il des enfants?"
Des cassettes comme ça c'est
angoissant.
- C'est très angoissant.
Un des facteurs de protection
pour la santé mentale des gens
dans un tel contexte,
c'est l'entourage. C'est la
proximité des proches.
Ici, les dilemmes et que
plusieurs scénarios peuvent être
envisagés. Il faut regarder les
risques et les bienfaits de
chacun des scénarios.
Effectivement c'est parfois
complexe à évaluer. De deux mots
souvent il faut choisir le
moindre.
- Quel est votre conseil Docteur
Weiss?
- C'est une situation complexe.
Probablement qu'il faudrait
s'assurer que ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui est symptomatique.
Je dirais que le gros défi qu'on
a eu à vivre aujourd'hui ce sont
les travailleurs de la santé.
C'est un problème majeur parce
que les travailleurs de la santé
depuis qu'on les isole,
et depuis quand ils sont
revenus. La grosse question de
savoir quand on est revenu à
partir de quand on isole. Si
vous arrivez aujourd'hui, vous
isole. Si vous êtes arrivé il y
a deux jours on ne vous isole
pas. Mais si vous êtes arrivé il
y a deux jours il y a des
chances que vous soyez en
période d'incubation et que vous
soyez malade dans quatre jours.
Pendant ces jours vous serez en
contact avec un paquet de gens
qui risquent de devenir malades.
Où est-ce qu'on va trancher la
ligne. Ça devient très complexe
pour les travailleurs de la
santé. Il faudra trancher
quelque part de façon claire.
Aussi c'est une gestion du
risque. Est-ce qu'on est prêt à
payer une certaine partie.
À partir d'aujourd'hui. Si on
mettait ça il y a 16 jours on
augmenterait la marge de
sécurité ou il y a 14 jours.
C'est une question de gestion
des risques de conflits on est
prêt à payer.
- Il pose bien la question,
Docteur Weiss. Comme on l'a dit,
on est passé d'un état antérieur
en une journée de façon
extensive et dans les prochains
jours il y aura des ajustements
et des éléments qui seront
présentés. Pris en
considération. Notamment pour
les éléments opérationnels sur
le terrain. On aboie avoir des
principes, on a changé de ton
et d'approche et maintenant il
faut le mettre en opération. Ça
se faire en lien avec les
acteurs. On va vivre, ce matin
quand la décision se prenait je
me disais : je voyais toute la
série de questions qui allaient
venir. Les impacts que ça peut
représenter. Je pense que c'est
un acte courageux, si vous me
permettez, de le dire.
Mais je pense qu'il faut le
mettre en opération et il faut
aussi être en train d'évaluer ce
qui est en train de se passer au
point de vue de l'épidémiologie
mais aussi commencer vécu sur le
terrain. L'objectif, c'est que
ça fonctionne et donc, pas de
l'annoncer à un principe ne pas
être capable de le mettre en
opération. Ces discussions
auront lieu avec les cliniciens,
les techniciens, les
entrepreneurs, les syndicats.
C'est vraiment un problème de
société. Et une action de
société nécessaire pour passer
au travers.
- D'où cet appel à la
solidarité.
- Exactement. Je vous le dis, le
citoyen doit être à l'écoute.
Il peut prendre des mesures.
Les gens, même si on met des
règles, il faut analyser chacune
des situations qui peuvent être
particulières. Maintenant je
pense qu'on a lancé le
changement de cap et on va
le mettre en opération et
essayer de répondre plus
rapidement possible aux
préoccupations.
- Une autre question :
Je pense que je connais un peu
la réponse Docteur Arruda.
- Je me suis fait poser la
question tellement de fois dans
ces derniers jours et je dis
clairement : si vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'y aller n'y aller pas.
C'est difficile d'annuler le
voyage qu'on a prévu. Ces
nouvelles vacances.
On a pas beaucoup d'occasions.
On comprend ça. C'est très
difficile. Mais d'un autre côté
au retour devra être en
quarantaine 14 jours.
- À cause des recommandations du
Québec.
- Tout à fait.
- Et c'est aussi pour la
protéger elle. Dans les faits,
c'est un acte social pour les
autres mais aussi pour leur
santé.
- À leurs frais très
probalbement aussi. S'il décide
de partir après l'annonce par le
gouvernement doive assumer la
responsabilité des conséquences
de la quarantaine imagine.
Vous voulez dire quelque chose?
- Souvent les compagnies
d'assurances à partir du moment
où il y a ce genre de
recommandations ne couvre pas
forcément les gens quand ils
vont à voyage.
À ce moment s'il tombe malade
dans un pays étranger où les
soins peuvent coûter très cher
et doivent assurer des frais qui
ne seront plus couverts.
Il y a cet aspect. Il y a aussi
l'aspect social. Voyager c'est
une question d'avantages et
inconvénients. Si les
inconvénients deviennent plus
problématiques plus gros que les
avantages... poser la question
c'est un peu y répondre.
- Coût bénéfice n'est pas
toujours là. Julie aimante à une
question des téléspectateurs.
- Une question qui revient
souvent concernant les
déplacements. Les voyages entre
autres. Plusieurs milliers de
personnes des Québécois entre
autres en Floride qui se demande
s'ils pourront revenir dans
trois semaines ou un mois.
Un téléspectateur de l'évidement
: peut-on s'attendre à ce que
les déplacements soient
perturbés à l'intérieur du pays.
Entre les provinces et les
territoires. Il demande aussi :
à partir de quels critères peut-
on mettre des villes et des
régions en confinement. En
quarantaine. Une question qui
suscite beaucoup de discussions
sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Actuellement, compte tenu de
la situation canadienne,
il n'y a pas de transmission
locale. Active, que l'on sache.
Pour le moment ce n'est pas le
cas.
- Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire?
- La majorité des fois ce sont
des gens qui sont venus de
l'extérieur. Il y a pu y avoir
quelqu'un de la famille qu'il a
fait. Mais sans que ce soit dans
la communauté où les gens l'ont
attrapé en allant dans le centre
d'achat, en prenant le transport
en commun.
- Même pas le cas du métro.
- On n'a pas démontré qu'il y
avait eu de transmission dans
ces cas.
Et on verra qu'est-ce qu'on
fera. Ce que disait Docteur
Tremblay tantôt par rapport à la
question des villes où vraiment
il y a eu une transmission,
ce qui se passe actuellement par
exemple en Italie, on est
complètement dans une autre
situation. Ça va être revu au
jour le jour. Quelle est les
critères, il n'y a pas de nombre
de cas. Par exemple, on avait 50
qui viennent tous de
l'extérieur. C'est très
différent de 50 dans une
communauté.
- On n'a pas entendu parler de
la l'hôpital Notre-Dame on avait
mis en été mis en isolement et
le personnel aussi.
- C'est ce qu'on fait. Il y a un
cas. Peut-être qu'il y a des
personnes qui ont été exposées à
la maison. Ce qu'on fait, c'est
qu'on regarde les personnes qui
auraient pu être exposées.
Elles sont isolées. S'il
développe des symptômes il va y
avoir des tests.
C'est de la gestion de la et de
contact.
- Comme il n'y a pas de
résultats encore on ne peut pas
parler de transmission locale.
S'il y avait des résultats,
en dispositif ça deviendrait une
transmission locale.
- En milieu hospitalier on parle
de transmission nosocomiale.
Local c'est dans la communauté.
Docteur Weiss peut en parler, ça
voudrait dire qu'il aurait pu y
avoir un genre de bris dans les
mesures de précaution et à ce
moment-là il peut y avoir
transmission.
- Tout à fait. La transmission
nosocomiale, la meilleure façon
de la prévenir c'est d'abord
d'être bien équipée.
Il y a l'aspect de l'équipement
qui est important. Et aussi la
suspicion du triage des
patients. La capacité de trier
ses patients. Là on voit qu'il y
a une augmentation du nombre
demandes, de test qu'on doit
faire. Une augmentation du
nombre de patients à trier.
Pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
transmission Québec à
l'intérieur de la communauté en
général. Pas complètement
différent de ce qui se passe
en Colombie-Britannique, mais
par contre il y a eu des cas
de gens qui ont été exposés dans
les hôpitaux à des gens qui
étaient malades. Donc il va
falloir s'assurer que ces gens-
là soient suivis.
Mais juste pour répondre, vous
donnez un exemple de comment ça
impacte un peu les choses,
nous on avait notre congrès
canadien annuel de maladie
infectieuse qui devait se tenir
à Vancouver au début du mois de
mai. Et le congrès n'aura
probablement pas lieu.
Vous voyez que tous les congrès
médicaux sont annulés.
D'autant plus qu'on ne veut pas
être tous les infectiologues
canadiens au même endroit en
même temps et malade.
- Ça ne serait pas sérieux.
D'ailleurs une annonce très
grande aujourd'hui de tous les
lieux culturels aussi
qui annulent toutes les
représentations. On poursuit
cette émission spéciale après la
pause. La France, Verlander la
Norvège ferme leurs écoles. Le
nombre de cas augmente partout
en Europe.
On parle à notre collaborateur
sur place au retour.
- Ce n'est pas la division qui
permettra de répondre à ce qui
est aujourd'hui une crise
mondiale.
- L'annonce hier soir du
président Trump, on peut le
dire, à semer sans doute la
consternation en Europe est
certainement la colère et la
frustration. Pour un peu savoir
quelle est la situation en
Europe et peut-être dans
d'autres pays, Julie Émond.
- Avec plaisir.
On fait un peu un portrait des
principaux pays les plus touchés
Anne-Marie. On commence bien sûr
avec l'Italie. On ne peut pas
passer à côté. D'importantes
mesures ont été annoncées
aujourd'hui. Déjà ces images qui
ont fait le tour de la terre
depuis plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines.
Des villes complètement
désertes. Des places publiques
désertées d'où l'pays qui a été
mis en quarantaine. On est rendu
à 15 000 qu'à 1000 morts. C'est
une hausse de plus de 20 % si on
compare à 24 heures à peine.
C'est énorme en termes de
victimes en Italie. Le pays au
complet et en quarantaine. Tous
les commerces sont fermés hormis
bien sûr les pharmacies les
épiceries. Tous les autres
commerces, les publics et les
écoles. On a annoncé des mesures
particulières du côté du
Vatican. Toutes les églises
catholiques sont fermées. Une
première dans l'histoire
moderne. Le papa lui-même
ordonné... donner l'autorisation
de manquer la messe du dimanche.
C'est vous dire. Surtout dans un
pays aussi catholique pratiquant
que l'Italie. Ce n'est pas rien.
En France maintenant,
là aussi, près de 3000
maintenant. 61 morts. Macron
demande aux gens les plus
vulnérables de rester à la
maison. Au Royaume-Uni
maintenant, près de 600 cas
confirmés à l'heure actuelle.
Une dizaine de morts.
On s'attend à ce que ça empire
selon Boris Johnson.
Il a ajouté que c'était la pire
crise sanitaire de sa
génération. En Espagne
maintenant : quatre localités de
la Catalogne ont été placées
sous confinement aujourd'hui.
Les écoles sont fermées dans la
région de Madrid.
Je termine avec la Norvège. 700
cas dont un mort. Les écoles
fermées. Tous les commerces sont
fermés saufs les épiceries et
les pharmacies. Nécessité
oblige. On a annoncé que les
exercices de l'OTAN étaient
suspendus. Je termine en disant
les gens à la maison qui veulent
nous envoyer les questions vous
pouvez le faire ici :
- merci Julie. Tout à l'heure.
On vient d'apprendre que la
tequila Slovaquie ont choisi de
fermer leurs frontières pour
limiter la propagation du virus.
Quelle est la situation,
le climat qui règne, en Europe,
je joins en quatre mères en
Europe à Bruxelles. Merci d'être
avec nous à cette heure tardive.
On le disait tout à l'heure, la
décision de Trump a certainement
semé la colère et la frustration
en Europe.
- Disant que les gens ont été
étonnés ici. Charles Michel,
président du conseil européen,
la présidente de la commission
ont dit qu'ils avaient été pris
par surprise. Ils ont découvert
l'annonce de Trump.
Il a évité soigneusement de
consulter les Européens. Son
argument a été de dire :
ça aurait pris trop de temps les
consulter. En l'occurrence on a
quand même des responsables qui
sont identifiés. L'union
européenne a désormais deux
numéros de téléphone.
Ce n'est pas très compliqué
d'avertir les partenaires
européens. Manifestement Trump a
décidé d'ajouter la crise à la
crise. Et détendre la panique un
peu surréaliste quand même
qui règne dans le monde depuis
l'apparition du coronavirus.
- Surtout qu'il parle d'un virus
étranger. Il reproche à l'Europe
de ne pas avoir pris ses
responsabilités. Évidemment en
visant peut-être chacun des
pays. Qu'en est-il vraiment en
Europe? De la capacité ou non de
freiner la propagation du virus.
Le président Macron a parlé ce
soir à la nation pour annoncer
aussi de nouvelles mesures.
- Absolument.
Mais d'abord, il faut dire que
les Américains sont un tantinet
gonflé, on va dire ça comme ça.
Parce que le coronavirus est
déjà chez eux et on voit que
depuis le début de cette crise,
les frontières ne servent
strictement à rien. Si les
frontières avaient servi à
quelque chose, par exemple en
1918, au moment où le monde
était séparé et en guerre
n'aurait pas eu la grippe
espagnole. Ça n'a rien empêcher.
C'est une façon pour lui de
rebondir parce qu'il a sous-
estimé l'ampleur de la crise
et l'ampleur surtout des
craintes des opinions publiques.
Et aujourd'hui, il fait porter
la faute d'abord sur les
Chinois, il est en guerre
commerciale avec la Chine est
maintenant sur les Européens. Il
est aussi en guerre commerciale
avec les Européens.
Il caresse son électorat dans le
sens du poil en expliquant à
quel point c'est des étrangers.
Mais en Europe c'est exactement
la même chose.
Vous l'avez dit vous-même, en
Slovaquie, en République
tchèque, on vient de fermer les
frontières. La frontière
italienne avec la France fermait
ce soir. En Allemagne, la
frontière entre la France et
l'Allemagne il y a des contrôles
de température qui est prise
pour toutes les voitures. Le
résultat c'est que vous avez
des heures et des heures
d'embouteillage aux frontières.
C'est une panique généralisée.
C'est un virus étranger et donc
on va le stopper en interdisant
toutes liaisons internationales,
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
ça. Si on pouvait arrêter
n'importe quoi enfermant sa
frontière, ça se saurait.
On n'a jamais réussi à arrêter
quoi que ce soit. Mais la
panique est maintenant générale.
Trump, en prenant cette
décision, donner un coup de pied
dans la fourmilière puisque les
Européens, depuis ce matin,
prennent des décisions dans tous
les sens. La commission par
exemple vient décrire un petit
recueil de toutes les décisions
qui ont été prises dans les
différentes régions européennes
parce qu'elles sont très
variées.
Ça se traduit en quelques mots
par un enfermement national.
Quelque part, l'Europe cherche à
sortir du monde, comme les
États-Unis cherchent à sortir du
monde. Je crois qu'Emmanuel
Macron l'a très bien dit quand
il a expliqué qu'aujourd'hui on
rentrait dans une heure des
démondialisation.
- En même temps il y a ses
capacités des systèmes de santé
en Europe de gérer la situation.
On a lu, entendu qu'en Italie
notamment devait choisir
entre brancher un appareil
respiratoire sur une personne
âgée ou une personne plus jeune.
En Espagne c'est l'état
d'urgence. Je ne sais pas quelle
est la situation en France.
Mais est-ce que niveau de
l'Europe on est capable de
prendre des mesures
communautaires pour venir en
aide à ces populations et
soutenir les systèmes de santé
qui connaîtrait les faiblesses?
- C'est une très bonne question.
Parce que la commission
européenne, l'exécutif européen
a tardé à prendre la mesure de
la crise et n'a pas proposé un
plan d'ensemble, un plan
d'action aux citoyens européens.
Aux gouvernements européens. En
disant : la santé n'est pas une
compétence communautaire.
La santé c'est la compétence des
états qui composent l'union
européenne. On peut seulement
appuyer l'action des états.
Donc, il a laissé la panique
s'installer. Mardi, il a fallu
que la France exige la réunion
de conseil européen des chefs
d'État de gouvernement.
Les 27 chefs d'État et de
gouvernements qui se sont réunis
par vidéoconférence. L'heurt
n'est plus haut rencontré aux
embrassades et aux poignées de
main. Pour couronner le début de
semblant de coordination.
Ça a volé en éclats aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est très compliqué de se
mettre d'accord sur les mesures
de santé. Encore une fois.
Comme vous le dîtes, les
systèmes de santé sont très
divers, ça dépend des états.
Et les états se sentent
responsables de la santé de la
population. D'où cette espèce de
florilège de mesures aussi
diverses que variées d'un État à
l'autre. Alors, on essaie de se
coordonner mais c'est long parce
qu'on est obligé de le faire en
pleine crise. Si on avait
commencé un mois et demi il en
essaie de se mettre d'accord. On
a été pris par surprise
exactement comment 2015 au
moment de la crise des migrants
et des réfugiés lorsque 1
million de réfugiés syriens
s'était rué en Grèce et sur la
route des Balkans pour
finalement être accueilli en
Allemagne. L'immigration n'était
pas une compétence européenne.
Il est devenu par la force des
choses. On essaie d'inventer un
traitement comme si vous voulez
d'une crise sanitaire.
- Dernière question rapidement :
est-ce qu'on comprend en Europe
exception faite par Donald Trump
quant au Royaume-Uni, son grand
ami? Boris Johnson a dit
aujourd'hui que c'était la pire
crise de l'histoire
- Alors, la pire crise il faut
quand même pas exagérer. Je
rappelle que 1000 morts pour
l'instant en Italie. La moyenne
d'âge des 81,4 ans. Il ne faut
pas exagérer. Il y a 4000 morts
sur les routes parents en Italie
à titre de comparaison. En
France chaque année la grippe
saisonnière fait 10 000 morts.
Tout ça pour amener un peu de
calme. Est-ce qu'on comprend
l'exception faite Royaume-Uni?
Évidemment pas. Vous oubliez de
citer l'Irlande qui n'est pas
non plus dans le ban.
Américain. C'est comme si le
monde anglo-saxon été immunisé
pas qu'il y avait une sorte
d'immunité anglophone. Non,
c'est totalement
incompréhensible. On voit bien
ce que vise à nouveau Donald
Trump, c'est véritablement
d'enfoncer un coin entre les
Européens. Il déteste l'union
européenne et voit dans cette
crise l'occasion de diviser pour
mieux régner.
- Merci, Jean IV mère, depuis
Bruxelles.
Et parlant de Donald Trump et de
la gestion de la crise aux
États-Unis, je joins Didier
Fassin, titulaire de la chaire
de santé publique au collège de
France. Merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous. Vous parlez à nos
téléspectateurs et des collègues
de santé publique sur notre
plateau ce soir.
Que s'est-il passé aux États-
Unis. Vous venez d'entendre
collègues européens critiquer la
décision de Trump. Quelle a été
votre réaction face à l'annonce
hier de Donald Trump de fermer
les frontières à l'heure.
- Je crois que c'est une
décision qui est d'abord absurde
comme on vient de l'évoquer
puisqu'on laisse entrer les
citoyens de Grande-Bretagne,
mais on ferme la porte aux
Polonais alors qu'il y a 10 fois
plus de cas dans le premier pays
que dans le second.
Mais surtout, c'est une mesure
qui est épidémiologique ment
inefficace puisqu'elle cherche
à faire croire que le virus
étranger, comme le dit le
président lui-même, alors
qu'aujourd'hui, problème États-
Unis est avant tout un problème
de contamination communautaire.
C'est-à-dire des gens qui, dans
leur quartier, dans leur
environnement, dans la réunion,
vont s'exposer à d'autres
personnes qui sont eux-mêmes...
affecté par le coronavirus.
Sans avoir voyagé.
Et puis troisièmement, c'est
une... une décision qui est
politiquement motivée de la
manière la plus déplaisante
puisque c'est une mesure
qui a un arrière-fond xénophobe.
Aujourd'hui même sur le site Web
de la Maison-Blanche était
affiché un article qui disait
que les politiques de lutte
contre l'immigration menée par
le gouvernement et le président
avait permis d'éviter l'arrivée
sur le territoire des États-Unis
250 000 personnes infectés par
le coronavirus.
- C'est incroyable.
- Donc on voit comment il s'agit
là d'une mesure encore une fois
absurde, inefficace et
démagogique.
- Quel est votre plus grande
crainte à ce moment-ci quant à
la propagation de la COVID 19?
On a beaucoup parlé depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà des
faiblesses du système et de
l'incapacité à le détecter,
faire subir l'test là où il le
fallait. On a muselé des
médecins notamment dans l'État
de Washington.
Je pense à cette docteure qui
avait repéré le coronavirus.
C'était silence radio du côté de
la CDC et de la FDA.
Est-ce qu'on peut encore faire
confiance? Quel est votre plus
grande crainte face à la gestion
de l'épidémie en ce moment... de
la pandémie?
- Se compléter effectivement
c'est que le dépistage ou l'test
tout simplement des personnes
suspectées du COVID 19
marche très, très mal.
Il y a moins d'une semaine, on
comptait à peine 5000 tests qui
avaient été réalisés.
C'était 700 fois moins,
rapportées à la population,
que la Corée du Sud.
On est là dans un dispositif ou
en atteste pas, ce qui fait
qu'on peut dire aussi évidemment
qu'on a peu de cas.
Mais il y a quand même 1600...
un peu plus de 1600 aujourd'hui
sont reconnus. Mais on voit bien
que ce déni qui s'associe avec
un déficit de testing conduit à
minimiser la réalité de
l'épidémie. Et donc à rendre
le travail de la santé publique
bien plus difficile.
S'ajoute à cela,
non plus haut niveau de la santé
publique
au niveau des hôpitaux, la prise
en charge des malades, quelque
chose qu'on connaît bien aux
États-Unis : à savoir les très
grandes inégalités qu'il y a
face à l'accès aux soins.
Le fait que 87 millions de
personnes aux États-Unis
sont peu ou mal assurés.
20 millions de leçons pas du
tout. Ce qui veut dire que ce
sont des gens qui ne vont pas se
faire soigner. Un certain nombre
parmi eux, on estime à 11
millions environ, sont des
personnes en situation
irrégulière. Mais souvent sur le
territoire depuis très
longtemps.
Et qui auront les plus grandes
réticences à aller à l'hôpital
lorsqu'ils seront malades.
Ou à faire tester.
On a toute une série d'éléments,
sans compter le fait que dans un
pays où il y a 38 millions de
travailleurs qui sont au-dessous
du seuil de pauvreté, et ça ne
concerne du reste pas seulement
ceux-là les gens préfèrent
continuer à travailler même si
ils sont malades plutôt que de
perdre des journées de
rémunération sachant qu'il n'y a
pas de système de protection
comme on peut avoir en Europe
et probablement aussi au Canada.
Pour les personnes qui sont
obligées de se mettre au repos
pour des raisons de maladie.
On a là un ensemble à la fois au
Donc on alla au niveau de la
prise en charge, une situation
qui est assurément préoccupante
je dirais d'autant plus
préoccupante que le gouvernement
ne veut pas l'affronter.
- Week Donald Trump est toujours
dans le déni et qu'il dit
toujours qu'il n'y a que 32
morts. Merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris la parole. Je suis persuadé
que l'on va se parler au cours
des prochaines heures sinon des
prochains jours.
- Merci à vous.
Bonsoir, bienvenue à cette
deuxième heure de notre émission
spéciale, Questions de
coronavirus.
L'émission Grands Reportages
Personnalité "Dany Turcotte,
L'urgence de vivre", sera
diffusée à une date ultérieure.
Au cours de la prochaine heure,
nos experts vont répondre
à d'autres questions que
vous nous avez envoyées.
Aussi, beaucoup de fausses
nouvelles circulent sur la
COVID-19. Comment séparer
le vrai du faux?
Il n'y a toujours pas de
directives de Québec concernant
les écoles, mais de plus en plus
de commissions scolaires
prennent elles-mêmes la
décision. Ces commissions
scolaires seront fermées demain:
-Marie-Victorin
-Riverside
-Des Hautes-Rivières
-Trois-lacs
-Chemin-du-Roy
-Du Pays des bleuets
-D l'Or-et-des-Bois
-De Saint-Hyacinthe
Également l'Université du Québec
à Chicoutimi.
Déjà l'Université de Montréal
avait fait parvenir des
consignes cet après-midi.
L'université Laval quant à elle
rest ouverte.
Alors on poursuit cette deuxième
avec mes invités Weiss,
Christelle Groulx, Madame
Tremblay et Horacio Arruda.
Réaction cette annonce des
commissions scolaires.
- Oui, il faut voir dans le
contexte ce que l'on a annonce
aujourd'hui, notamment la
question des rassemblements et
tout ça, dans le contexte des
gens qui reviennent de semaine
de relâche, il y a certaines
personnes qui ont décidé
actuellement de fermer et on va
réévaluer sa notamment demain
avec le ministère de
l'Éducation, puis avec le bureau
du premier ministre sur les
modalités.
- Est-ce que ça pourrait
s'étendre aux garderies aux
universités?
- Je veux dire, tout est
possible. Je ne peux pas vous
dire, parce que ça va dépendre
de la situation. Mais il faut
voir la commission des
commissions scolaires surtout
actuellement associées au retour
de la semaine de relâche.
Et ayant appris que des salles
de 250 personnes, c'était peut-
être une question de logistique.
Il y a aussi là-dedans la prise
en compte de la crainte de
certains parents actuellement et
je pense que devant le fait de
cela, il nous reste une journée,
ils ont décidé de fermer mais en
vain réévaluer tout ça au
courant de la fin de semaine.
- Très bien, on va aller aux
questions du public.
J'imagine que ça fait parti de
l'évaluation.
- Tout à fait. Il va y avoir des
consignes données aux
commissions scolaires.
Premièrement, par rapport aux
cafétérias. Étaler les dîners.
Changer les dîners. Tout va
dépendre de la transmission que
l'on va voir. On n'en a pas
encore de le calmer dès
maintenant, il va y avoir des
conseils par rapport à l'hygiène
comme telle, on va devoir
augmenter les périodes, peut-
être distancé les dîners.
- Céderait combien de temps de
fermeture des écoles idéalement?
14 jours, 30 jours.
- Ça va dépend de la situation.
Tant qu'il y a de la
transmission, on pourrait la
fermer, mais il faudra attendre
que ne s'arrête la transmission.
Pourrait prendre des semaines il
ne faut pas oublier que
lorsqu'on ferme les écoles, les
parents doivent rester à la
maison. Avoir un impact sur la
force de travail. Dans le réseau
de la santé, imaginez-vous aussi
les infirmières, les
inaltérables, du personnel de la
santé, les techniciens de
laboratoire ne rentrent pas
travailler parce que les enfants
sont à la maison, à ce moment-
là, ça a un impact sur notre
capacité à répondre. C'est là le
problème. Alors qu'est-ce que
l'on fait? Est-ce qu'on organise
des écoles garderies dans les
hôpitaux pour permettre à ces
gens-là, mais d'un autre côté,
en faisant cela, rappelez-vous,
les enfants sont des vecteurs
d'infection. Il y a toujours des
questions qu'il faut se poser.
- Est un moment donné, car c'est
tellement circulant dans la
communauté, ça peut devenir une
mesure qui a plus de contraintes
que de bénéfices.
- Vous voulez dire de fermer les
écoles?
- Bien oui, si jamais il y a
tellement de transmission
partout, puis en plus on
démontre que ce n'est pas
nécessairement le milieu
scolaire qui est amplificateur
du virus, fermer les écoles et
de créer tous les problèmes aux
parents etc., ça peut devenir un
problème. Ça peut être adéquat
dans des pas initiales, mais il
y a toujours plusieurs facteurs
à regarder dans ces éléments-là.
Comprenez-vous. C'est sûr que le
jour, où il se met... quand il a
de la circulation partout et que
l'on a perdu un peu le contrôle,
bien de maintenir, d'arrêter des
activités qui sont essentielles,
qui ont des impacts comme l'a
dit le docteur Karl Weiss sur le
personnel, sur les parents, sur
les familles, il va falloir
réévaluer.
- Il serait mieux d'être à
l'école parce que le risque est
faible.
- Oui, puis dans les faits, en
les ramenant, en les sortant de
l'école, on peut les envoyer
dans des milieu où il pourrait y
avoir encore de la transmission.
- En éthique clinique, on dit
souvent que le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien. C'est l'examen
des scénarios que les gens
doivent faire effectivement pour
anticiper les conséquences des
actions. Ce que je voulais dire
surtout, c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a des mesures comme ça,
les faits, c'est d'augmenter
l'inquiétude de la population.
Alors qu'il faudrait quand même
que la population comprenne que
c'est rassurant, c'est-à-dire
que quand il y a une décision,
mais c'est paradoxal, quand il y
a décision comme ça qui se
prend, ça donne une impression
subjective qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est infiniment plus
grave qu'hier, alors qu'il y a
une décision qui s'est prise qui
est une décision protectrice,
préventive et protecteur presse
de la population.
Mais je veux juste dire que
Auchan qui s'appelle était
paradoxal mais qu'il faut quand
même comprendre que dans le
fond, il y a un ensemble de
mesures de protections qui sont
mises en place.
Alors la nouvelle et
inquiétante, mais il reste que
cette nouvelle protectrice.
- Un dernier mot là-dessus
Madame Tremblay.
- Un des problèmes à prendre
cette décision, c'est qu'il y a
des inconnus. C'est qu'il y a
des choses que l'on ne connaît
pas par rapport à ce virus en
particulier, on ne sait pas quel
rôle les enfants jouent comme
vecteurs ou transmetteurs. Du
fait que ces particuliers par
rapport à d'autres épidémies. On
savait avec l'influence et le
stress que les enfants pouvaient
être très malade. Ils deviennent
des vecteurs importants. Dans ce
cas-ci, on ignore encore ces
éléments-là ça n'est pas prendre
des décisions.
- Alors emballé à une brève
pause et on se retrouve tout de
suite après.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'mission spéciale question de
coronavirus se poursuit jusqu'à
21 heures.
On en parlait brièvement après
la pause, mais qui n'a toujours
pas de directives concernant les
écoles, le Docteur Horacio
Arruda nous disait que
l'agression allait très examiner
au cours des prochaines heures.
Mais sachez que dès ce soir, des
commissions scolaires prennent
la décision de fermer leurs
portes dès demain. Marie,,
Riverside, des hautes Rivières,
chemin du roi, du pays des
bleuets, de l'or et des bois, et
Saint-Hyacinthe et des collèges
privés aussi ont annoncé leur
fermeture. Alors j'imagine que
les personnes intéressées ont
déjà été informées de la chose.
Et notre collègue
Thomas Gerbet a tourné des
images au maxi de Saint-Michel à
Montréal où on prévient les
clients à l'entrée qu'il y a
deux heures d'attente aux
caisses, mais la plupart entrent
quand même.
- On voit avec ces images marie
qu'il y a quand même un peu, je
ne veux pas dire... comment
qualifier les derniers jours,
des gens qui se russe dans les
magasins à grande surface, dans
les marchés d'alimentation pour
faire des provisions. C'est ce
que l'on a remarqué au cours des
derniers jours, qui veulent
accumuler des quantités
importantes de denrées non
périssables ou encore de papier
de toilette, disons-le, c'est ce
que l'on a vu beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux.
Il y a des questions qui vont
dans ce sens, dans le sens des
épiceries, des lieux publics
continue de fréquenter malgré
cette interdiction d'événements
de plus grande ampleur.
Très bonne question.
Je termine avec quelques
questions en vrac parce que l'on
reçoit des milliers de
questions. Je n'ai jamais vu ça.
Beaucoup de personnes
s'interrogent du fait que les
casinos demeurent ouvert.
Plusieurs commentaires en ce
sens. Je vous redonne la parole
et je vous reviens avec d'autres
questions.
- Garder les tableaux pas loin,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions.
- Sur la question du virus sur
les surfaces inertes, les
coronavirus sont des virus qui
peuvent persister sur des
surfaces inertes pendant
quelques heures à quelques
jours. Donc ils peuvent rester
là. Ça va dépendre aussi si la
surface est humide ou si elle
est sèche. Donc c'est une bonne
idée, c'est pour cela que l'on
recommande aux gens de
désinfecter les surfaces sur
lesquelles il prépare la
nourriture et de se laver les
mains régulièrement après avoir
touché un panier à provisions,
c'est une très bonne chose de se
laver les mains. Ceci dit, c'est
un virus qui est très facile à
détruire parce que c'est un
virus avec une enveloppe, donc
avec les produits de nettoyage
habituel, c'est-à-dire ce qui va
être facilement éliminé. Sur la
nourriture, on ne pense pas que
c'est un problème. Il n'y a pas
d'évidence de transmission, ce
que l'on appelle fécale orale,
en mangeant de ce virus la. Ça
été regardé en Chine, là où il y
a eu le plus de cas. On pense
que c'est un problème. De toute
façon va toujours recommander
aux gens de laver leurs fruits
et légumes. Ça devrait être
suffisant pour s'en débarrasser.
- Autre question, les femmes
enceintes sont-elles plus
vulnérables?
- Les coronaires virus
habituellement ne sont pas
connues pour donner des
malformations. Mais par contre,
la fièvre, on sait que la
sienne, ce n'est jamais bon
quand on est enceinte.
Premièrement. Si vous attrapez
le coronavirus et que vous êtes
enfin, le fait d'avoir de la
fièvre, ça peut être
problématique. La deuxième chose
importante à souligner, c'est
que les femmes enceintes ont
habituellement à la grossesse un
état immunitaire un peu diminué.
On l'a vu avec l'influenza,
l'influenza est beaucoup plus
chez les femmes enceintes que
chez les femmes du même âge en
bonne santé. Donc on n'a pas de
données en ce moment chez les
femmes enceintes coronavirus.
Mais c'est sûr qu'il va falloir
accumuler des données évidemment
les femmes enceintes, il faut
les protéger. Éventuellement, la
journée où on aurait un vaccin
efficace que l'on pourra donner
aux femmes enceintes, ce serait
un groupe prioritaire.
- En attendant quels conseils?
- Les conseils généraux de faire
attention. C'est sûr que
souvent, quand elles sont
enceintes, ils ont peut-être
d'autres enfants en bas âge
autour d'elle qui eux aussi
peuvent être des vecteurs de
contamination. Il faut faire
encore plus attention.
Donc c'est un ensemble de
mesures qu'il va falloir faire
chez les femmes enceintes. C'est
sûr que les voyages et les
femmes enceintes, ce n'est
vraiment pas le meilleur moment
dans le contexte actuel mesures
générales.
Puis les animaux, non, à date,
il ne faut pas trop s'inquiéter.
- Et le casino reste ouvert.
- Écoutez, c'est à évaluer.
C'est un peu, comment je
pourrais vous dire ça, à moins
qu'ils appliquent de la
distanciation...
- Mais votre recommandation de
250 personnes.
- Oui et c'est un endroit clos.
On a fait l'annonce aujourd'hui.
Ça amène toute une série de
questions. Ça fait parti des
choses que l'on va évaluer comme
tel, parce que... c'est sûr
qu'actuellement, il n'y a pas de
transmission locale. Ça serait
peut-être un élément peut-être
de transmission locale, à moins
que toutes les les clientèles
viennent à l'extérieur du pays.
C'est à regarder. C'est des
éléments qu'il faudra analyser
notamment avec nos partenaires
de Loto-Québec.
Toute la machine, parce que
cette nouvelle approche
impliquait déjà, mais encore
plus maintenant, différentes
parties du gouvernement.
- Les machines à sous, ça doit
être pas mal sales, les cartes,
les jetons... Ah!
- Le message c'est que oui, il
faut des désinfecter mais il ne
faut pas se fier sur les autres.
On n'est jamais aussi bien servi
que par soi-même. Lavez-vous les
mains.
- On a toujours un lavabo à
côté. Quand même. On peut avoir
du désinfectant. Sur les images
de mon collègue Thomas Gerbet,
deux heures d'attente dans un
maxi. On a rapporté que dans un
IGA à Saint-Lambert, les
tablettes étaient vident. Quel
conseil donnez-vous?
- Il y a deux types de penser
que les gens vont avoir car il y
a des annonces comme ça. Il va y
avoir des pensées constructives
il va y avoir des pensées qui
sont un peu parasitaires. Les
pensées parasitaires, c'est
celle qui tourne en boucle, les
ruminations et c'est celle qui
nous rende impuissante. Les
pensées constructives, celles
qui nous font prendre action.
C'est un comportement qui fait
en sorte que les gens ont
l'impression d'avoir le contrôle
sur une situation. Ce n'est
peut-être pas nécessairement
toujours le meilleur facteur de
protection. Mais à tout le
moins, c'est une action qui
permet aux gens de se restaurer.
- Bon, très bien. On va aller à
une pause. On vient de émettre
des mesures concernant Via Rail.
Je vous en parlerai après la
pause. Au retour, j'aimerais
parler de l'incapacité de
dépister ce fameux 811. On a
parlé de difficultés, de deux
heures d'attente pour avoir la
ligne. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
façons pour détecter, dépister
le virus.
Rester avec nous, l'émission se
♪ ♪ ♪
- Question de coronavirus se
poursuit avec toute une question
de Marie-Claude Chayer.
Comme c'est le retour de la
relâche, certains sont partis en
voyage, sont allés en croisière.
Au vu de mes réponses, il n'y a
pas lieu de me tester pour la
COVID-19. J'ai sûrement une
grippe saisonnière. Je trouve
l'équation un peu simple. C'est
peut-être la difficulté en ce
moment, c'est que les gens ont
peur, imagine qu'elles sont
porteurs s'ils ont un symptôme
de rhume et Toussaint ils sont
presque obligés de s'auto
diagnostiquer pour le 811 ça
prend deux heures d'attente.
- C'est inacceptable. Je tiens à
vous le dire. Ce n'est pas cela
que l'on vise comme système. Il
y a des gens qui ne sont pas
malades et qui n'ont pas de
symptômes qui appellent 811, ce
qui amène des problèmes. Il faut
avoir une plus grande capacité
de faire les choses. Vient de
mettre en place des cliniques
tout récemment. À ce moment si
commande voulait pas que ça
devienne clinique pour la gré
pour les autres infections,
comme ça ne circule pas, on est
passé à travers le 811 mais tous
cela va être réévalués. Il y a
une nouvelle ligne qui est là,
et je demande aux gens qui
veulent avoir des informations,
d'appeler à cette ligne là. Si
les gens à cette ligne se
rendent compte qu'il y a des
symptômes, ils vont vous
référer. Elle n'est pas encore
24 heures. À la limite, quand
les cliniques sont connues et
que l'on va et en circulation de
coronavirus au Québec, à ce
moment-là, on pourra peut-être
donner un accès différent à ces
cliniques.
- Si on croit être porteur du
virus, on appelle 811. Il faut
être patient. Ça ne fonctionne
pas toujours. Il n'y a que la
Montérégie, Québec Montréal.
Qu'est-ce que l'on passionnait
en Gaspésie, en Beauce, en
Abitibi?
- Si vous appelez le 811 en
Gaspésie ou en Beauce, je sais
qu'il y a une décentralisation,
mais ce que je veux vous dire,
ce que l'on va augmenter les
effectifs 811. Serait de donner
une meilleure réponse réévalués
à mon avis le système. Si le
système par 811 est trop long et
que les gens n'ont pas accès à
un test alors qu'il devrait être
testé, on devra le réévaluer.
- On nous informe que Québec a
mis fin à la saison du hockey
mineur.
- Étant donné que toutes les
ligues majeures ont mis fin à
leur saison, je pense que c'est
très logique.
- Revenons à la capacité de
détecter parce qu'on a vu qu'aux
États-Unis, il y a tellement de
critères, ici le critère, c'est
j'ai un symptôme, je passe par
le 811 et je peux aller à la
clinique. Parce qu'il ne faut
pas éliminer le plus de
barrières possibles pour le
dépistage?
- Oui tout à fait. Ça fait
longtemps que l'on pose le
gouvernement allait délocaliser
des centres hospitaliers. Il y a
trois ou quatre semaines que
l'on dit il faut plus de tests,
il faut augmenter notre
capacité. Il ne faut pas voir
tous les tests à une place parce
que s'il y a un problème à cette
place, vous imaginez les
conséquences pour le système.
Les tests, c'est notre seul
outil pour gérer cette éclosion.
La facilité des tests, c'est
d'avoir la première ligne. La
première ligne n'était pas
prête. Si vous alliez dans une
clinique il y a une semaine, les
médecins de famille sont démunis
par rapport à tout ça. C'est
clair que la première ligne
n'était pas prête. Même en
médecine spécialisée, il y a des
médecins spécialistes qui ont
leur propre clinique qui n'était
pas prêt. Imaginez-vous, vous
allez voir votre obstétricien
gynécologue clinique et vous
êtes malade, il n'y avait pas de
protocole.
- Est-ce qu'il y en a
?
- Ça s'améliore. Il y a toute
une organisation logistique
devra se faire rapidement.
- Qu'est-ce que vous dîtes sur
les régions à nouveau?
- Selon l'organisation des
services, chacun des PDG va
s'organiser pour identifier un
endroit où ça devra se faire. Et
puis si vous me permettez,
on est à évaluer effectivement
un transfert de à un seul
endroit, ça va être très
important surtout quand on aura
attesté beaucoup de monde
attesté en même temps.
- Vous avez dit que ça ne
faisait que commencer. On va
être confronté à des milliers de
tests.
- Et on ne parle pas en termes
de semaine. Je pense que c'est
assez urgent d'arriver à cette
décentralisation parce que l'on
voit que le nombre de tests doit
augmenter. Présentement, il n'y
a que le laboratoire de santé
publique du Québec qui fait tous
les tests au Québec. Et puis il
travail... ce sont des anges. Il
travaille extrêmement bien. Ceux
qui ont développé le test. Ils
sont en train de valider avec
d'autres experts de la façon de
décentraliser pour que les
hôpitaux puissent avoir des
- Ça va se faire dans combien de
temps?
- Il faut comprendre à une
séquence dans les deux premières
semaines de janvier il a fallu
développer le test. Il a fallu
le valider avec le laboratoire.
Il ne faut pas que les gens
pensent qu'on laisse et
qu'automatiquement le test est
fait. Il faut assurer la
qualité. Avant, on doit avoir
une confirmation avait avant le
laboratoire de Winnipeg, et
maintenant on peut transiter
cela vers d'autres
établissements. Il ne faut pas
non plus que les gens pensent
qu'on a le test, on le fait. Il
faut s'assurer des quantités et
il faut s'assurer de l'expertise
et que le test, je suis
convaincu que ce sera le cas, il
sera aussi bon dans les centres
hospitaliers que celui du
ministère.
- Dernière question avant
d'aller à la pause. On sait que
Trump dit qu'il y a des tests
partout disponibles, et on sait
que ce n'est pas vrai qu'il y a
des millions de qui ne sont pas
en attente. Il en faut combien
ici de milliers de millions de
tests? Et qui les fabrique? Ça
se fabrique ici? C'est long?
- Celle laboratoire de santé
publique à développer ces tests
avec les hôpitaux.
- On ne parlait pas de petits
kits de tests.
- Je veux vraiment dire que
nous, on a été exemplaire en
termes de tests. Si on se
compare aux États-Unis, on est
champion. Au SPQ, ils ont
développé le test de jours après
que la séquence a été connue.
C'est extraordinaire. Il faut
vraiment le souligner.
- Il n'y a pas de pénurie de
tests.
- Ce sont des tests maison.
- Je tiens à vous dire
qu'actuellement, on est en
situation où on est correcte,
mais on ne peut pas rester en
disant qu'on est correct
présentement. La masse de test
qui va s'installer, il va
falloir passer. Il faut regarder
les substrats, voir s'il n'y a
pas un test qui sera organisé
différemment pour les cliniques.
Et là-dessus nos
microbiologistes et ceux qui
sont dans les rabatteurs, ils
sont dans les grosses
universitaires et vont
travailler avec le SPQ. On est
capable de tests, on n'a pas de
problème mais il y a une
augmentation importante des il y
a de la circulation et composa
le diagnostic il va falloir
augmenter la capacité. On est en
train de travailler là-dessus.
- Un dernier mot?
- Je repense à la courbe que le
docteur Horacio Arruda avait
présentée au début c'était très
parlant.
- Merci d'être là. Ils restent
encore plusieurs minutes cette
émission spéciale. Plusieurs
questions aussi.
Cette émission se poursuit au
retour.
Question de coronavirus se
poursuit. On a reçu des
centaines et des centaines de
questions.
Nous essayons de les regrouper
soit par thème, pour que vous
puissiez être bien informé.
C'est le but de cette émission.
Aujourd'hui il y a un appel au
calme, à la solidarité mais
aussi un appel à la prise de
conscience de ce qui se
passerait réellement parce qu'on
nous dit que ça pourrait durer
longtemps. Non pas pour vous
angoisser mais sans doute pour
que chaque citoyen prenne ses
responsabilités. Julie Émond a
fait la synthèse de quelques-
unes de vos questions.
En rafale, allez-y.
- Quatre davantage sur le milieu
de l'attente étant donnés nos
intervenants sur le plateau.
Voici les trois premières en
rafale. D'abord on sait qu'il y
a ce fameux vaccin, on vaccine
les jeunes enfants sur la
pneumonie à pneumocoque. Est-ce
que celui-ci serait efficace
pour diminuer les effets
secondaires associés au
coronavirus? Un patient qui a
été dit Guéry, qui a donc réussi
à vaincre la maladie, est-il
immunisé? Est-il encore
contagieux, peut être vecteur de
propagation? On pose la question
sur l'hygiène nasale, les
solutions salines pour nettoyer
les sécrétions nasales. Est-ce
que ça a un effet pour diminuer
les effets secondaires du
coronavirus? Les trois autres
questions en rafale. Je vous
laisse sur ce tableau.
Les employés qui sont très
nombreux dans un lieu, on pense
à une usine ou par exemple une
salle de nouvelles peut-être ou
un portail médiatique comme
c'est le cas ici, est-ce que
lieu comme celui-là dans une
usine par exemple, où il y a
plus de 300 ou 400 employés,
est-ce que ça pose des questions
de sécurité là aussi? Un
fonctionnaire par exemple qui
déciderait d'aller en vacances
et qui sait qu'il sera en
quarantaine forcée payée au
retour, comment on juge et
comment on jauge tout ça? Et
pour les personnes sont
prisonnières ou encore qui sont
à mobilité réduite, avons-nous
prévu une quelconque trousse ou
un moyen de permettre le
dépistage à domicile? Une rafale
de questions, je vous laisse ce
tableau.
- Alors vaccin.
- Présentement, il n'y a pas de
vaccin efficace contre le
coronavirus. Il y a des vaccins
qui sont à l'excès. Il y a trois
produits qui sont, qui vont
entrer dans les essais cliniques
dans le prochain mois, moi qui
suis, sur des vrais patients,
des phases 1, juste pour évaluer
la sécurité, ensuite des phases
2 et 3. Prend une année avant
qu'on puisse avoir un vaccin qui
puisse être déployé largement.
Mais il y a des bons prospects
et ça regarde bien. Ceci dit, la
vaccination habituelle que les
enfants doivent avoir, et
doivent continuer à la voir.
Mais ça ne protégera pas contre
ce virus en particulier est une
chose qui est notable dans cette
maladie, c'est que les gens qui
développent la maladie, la forme
sévère, et qui décède, ne décède
pas de surinfection bactérienne
comparativement à l'influenza.
Il décède du virus d'une
inflammation massive qui arrive
dans les poumons et non pas de
complications.
- On ne sait pas pourquoi ça a
qu'une personne plus que
l'autre.
- Non, on sait que les personnes
plus âgées sont à risque d'avoir
une infection plus sévère. Alors
un patient Guéry était immunisé?
- En théorie, oui. La question
insiste coronavirus va devenir
endémique ou s'il va
disparaître. Ce que je veux dire
par là, si c'est un épisode qui
arrive une fois, tout le monde
attrape ou une grosse partie de
la population, il disparaît et
on n'en entend plus parler un
peu comme le SRAS il y a
quelques années. Augustin, qui
va se développer et s'adapter
pour devenir une forme
d'influenza, c'est-à-dire que
dans les années à venir, il va
toucher la population moins
sévèrement.
Hélas, évidemment l'avenir nous
le dira si on aura besoin de
vaccin, une fois au 5 août une
fois par année. Mais pour
l'instant si vous l'attrapez,
oui, vous serez guéri.
Vous allez avoir des anticorps.
- Et l'efficacité de l'hygiène
nasale?
- Aucune donnée dit que c'est
plus efficace ou que ça vous
protège contre quoi que ce soit.
Au contraire, plus vous touchez
votre que vous avez des chances
de vous mettre des micros dans
le nez que vous ne devriez pas
maître.
- La bouche, le nez et les yeux,
c'est à éviter.
Les employés nombreux dans un
espace parce que ça a dû guider
votre décision aujourd'hui de
limiter les rassemblements à 250
personnes.
- Mais ça n'empêche pas, surtout
quand il y aura de la
circulation active, de.. je vous
l'ai dit, ce n'est pas parce
qu'on est à 212, je veux être
clair avec ça, et dans une pièce
très petite, si on est en pleine
situation où il y a de la
circulation et qu'il y a des
gens qui sont enrhumés etc., on
peut décider d'avoir d'autres
méthodes. Surtout si la réunion
n'est pas absolument
essentielle. Il y a des
questions de télétravail,
également des vidéoconférences.
Je pense que ce sont des
pratiques qu'il faut commencer à
instaurer et qui vont être bon
et aider.
- Il faut être à proximité de la
personne contaminée.
- Ça se transmet habituellement
par gouttelettes et en milieu de
soins, il peut y avoir les
aérosols. Et ça dépend aussi si
les gens, dans quelle phase ils
sont au niveau des symptômes. Il
n'y a pas de grandes
habituellement d'être à peu près
à 1 m ou de mettre des personnes
" il n'y a pas de garantie à 100
%. Mais c'est un facteur qui
joue pour diminuer le risque.
- La question sur la trousse de
dépistage est intéressant parce
que ça pose la question comment
on fait le dépistage avec les
fameux tests. C'est une question
pertinente?
- Très pertinente. Je crois
qu'il faut mettre la population
en garde acheter d'pseudo kits
de dépistage qui peut
s'aventurer terne parce que dans
ce genre de situation, tout peut
sortir et il y a des choses déjà
qu'ils ont été rapportés par
rapport à cela. Il faut faire
attention il faut que ce soit
bien fait. La façon dont on fait
un dépistage habituellement, on
prend une espèce de tige et on
fait un prélèvement dans le nez,
on va chercher votre pharynx,
un peu comme une culture de
gorge, et entre les deux
échantillons, on les met dans un
milieu de transport et on va les
tester. On ne veut pas faire à
la maison aujourd'hui. Il y a
aussi de façon de bien faire le
prélèvement parce que si on ne
le fait pas bien, on peut avoir
un faux négatif. Ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on va faire
soi-même pour l'instant à la
maison.
- Avant d'aller à la pose nous
informe qu'une ligne
téléphonique, ça ne marche pas
bien non plus, votre ligne
générale.
- Merci de m'informer. C'est
pour ça qu'il faut être en
contact avec le terrain.
- On nous dit de rappeler plus
tard. Votre appel est important
pour nous!
- Je m'excuse.
On va apporter les ajustements.
J'espère que mes collègues qui
s'occupent de ce secteur sont en
à l'écoute actuellement.
- Merci encore une fois à tous
les quatre.
On poursuit l'émission après la
pause. On aura avec eux le
décrypteur, Jeff Yates.
Le spécialiste des infos
nouvelles et des théories du
complot. Beaucoup de fausses
nouvelles circulent. On avait
des experts aujourd'hui. C'est
important de s'en remettre à la
science pour prendre les bonnes
décisions et adopter les bons
comportements.
On se retrouve après la pause.
- Il n'y a pas que le virus et
la peur qui se propage en
situation de pandémie, mais
aussi la désinformation et les
fausses nouvelles, les théories
du complot. On a évité mon
collègue Jeff Yates à départager
le vrai du faux, spécialisée
dans les fausses nouvelles à
l'émission les décréta. Bonsoir.
Vous devez être débordé!
- Depuis le début de cette crise
que je n'ai jamais vu ça. Ça
fait cinq ans que je couvre les
fausses nouvelles et je n'ai
jamais vu autant de fausses
informations autour d'un seul
événement. Je sais que mes
collègues dans les médias de
vérification le font partout
dans le monde et c'est partout
la même chose, on est débordé,
on reçoit des questions à
chaque, que ce soit sur
Facebook, par courriel, des
questions vraiment chaque jour.
- 7° virus créés en laboratoire,
une arme biologique...
- Au début, ça tourne autour de
sa de la provenance virus.
Acommencer à faire les
manchettes, on se donnait toutes
sortes d'histoires sur d'où
venait le virus. Une des
premières théories qu'on a
couverts sur le court navire
c'était que ça provenait d'un
laboratoire à Winnipeg et qui
avait été envoyé secrètement en
Chine à Wuhan par de supposés
espions chinois. Ce n'était pas
la route mais les gens, faute
d'information, quand une crise
éclate comme ça, on a pas toutes
les réponses, les médias non
plus. C'est très difficile
d'aller voir sur le terrain en
Chine ce qui se passe. Dans ce
vide information, les gens
essayaient eux-mêmes de trouver
les réponses en cherchant sur le
Web, et souvent il se vit à des
sources qui n'en sont pas très
fiables. Dès le début, on jette
le doute sur ça, on disait que
c'était une arme biologique,
toute de théories comme ça.
C'est absolument faux bien sûr.
- Trump a laissé entendre que
c'était un complot démocrate.
- Au Venezuela, on dit que c'est
un complot de la sériée pour
miner la confiance du monde
envers la Chine. Tout le monde
pour faire de la politique.
- M. Horacio Arruda, vous avez
tout un défi.
- Un grand défi de
communication. Comme société,
nous en santé publique, nos
collègues médecins qui
connaissent bien aussi, et que
voulez-vous, l'influenza qui
existe depuis des siècles,
coronavirus, ce ne sont pas des
complots. Mais les gens aiment
utiliser cela
- et le coronavirus est une
exagération des médias alors
c'est pire que la grippe
saisonnière.
- L'idée est qu'on n'en parle
beaucoup trop et que c'est une
exonération et que c'est la même
chose que la grippe, il y a la
grippe chaque année et chaque
année des gens meurent à cause
de la grippe. Cette idée que
c'est tout simplement une
exagération, cette année pour ce
virus précisément.
- Précision parce qu'il a peut-
être eu de la confusion. M.
Trump l'a dit, influenza, on dit
encore que le risque est faible
mais on dit que l'influenza tue
beaucoup plus de monde. Mais on
commence à dire peut-être que ce
virus va finir par tuer plus de
monde. Est-ce que c'est ça
quand? Où est la vérité?
- C'est la proportion
finalement, c'est-à-dire que ce
que l'on sait que ce virus sont
au exact de mortalité, on ne le
connaît pas, c'est entre 1 % et
3 %. L'influenza régulière à un
taux de mortalité aux alentours
de 0,1 %. Mais on s'aperçoit que
la mortalité de ce virus avec ce
que l'on voit en Italie n'est
pas négligeable et comme disait
ma collègue avant cela, c'est
une maladie qui est très
inflammatoire. C'est un peu
bizarre. C'est une maladie qui
tue les gens par beaucoup de
destruction au niveau de leur
système immunitaire. C'est
quelque chose de nouveau et
c'est un virus qui est inconnu
pour l'espèce humaine. On ne l'a
jamais rencontré. Il faut qu'on
la prévoit, il faut apprendre à
le connaître, ce qu'on fait avec
influenza. Tous ces éléments
font que c'est plus difficile à
gérer.
- Ce qu'on a fait au début,
c'est vrai qu'on a comparé le
coronavirus avec influenza pour
deux raisons : parce que ça
transmet de la même façon,
c'était pour donner une idée aux
gens d'avoir un point de repères
pour pouvoir savoir quelles
mesures de prévention et de. Et
aussi pour relativiser les
choses parce que les gens
voyaient ça comme une grosse
menace avec toutes les théories
du complot, etc. Et il ne voyait
pas nécessairement la menace
habituelle que l'on acquiert
influenza. Ceci dit, ce sont des
maladies différents. Et plus
l'épidémie évolue, plus on
connaît les manifestations
cliniques. Et on est plus
capable de cibler aussi les
populations à risque les plus
vénérables. Donc ça permet un
peu de distinguer les deux.
- C'est la Chine qui nous en
apprend beaucoup?
- Ils en répondent beaucoup de
publications, les gens sont
critiques par rapport à la Chine
mais du point de vue
scientifique ils ont été très
rapides. Quand ils ont partagé
la séquence, ça été très
important pour tout le reste de
la science. Ils ont beaucoup de
publications où on nous décrit
les cas et on apprend beaucoup
de cela.
- Différents remèdes et conseils
bidons?
- Les gens essaient de profiter
de la crise en vendant toutes
sortes de produits sur les
réseaux sociaux. Quelqu'un sur
le Web qui essaie de vendre un
vaccin contre le coronavirus à
400 $ ne fonctionne pas, bien
sûr. Mais toute sorte de remède
maison circule, par exemple
certains disent que l'ail tu le
connais virus. Aujourd'hui, on a
vu très bizarre qui dit que le
coronavirus meurt à 26 °C, alors
il faut boire du café et du thé
pour augmenter sa température
avait 10° alors que notre
température corporelle a plus
haute que ça à la base. Il y a
confusion autour de cela,
j'essaie de trouver des
solutions parce qu'il n'y a pas
de vaccin, parce qu'il n'y a pas
de traitement connu. On cherche
d'remède maison, des trucs et
des astuces. Encore là, faut pas
se fier à des astuces convois
dans une publication Facebook
dans une image. Il faut se fier
aux autorités et à l'information
qui est fiable.
- Il a quand même ses troubles
psychiatriques avec la chaleur
ça partirait. Aujourd'hui, vous
avez dit et d'autres l'ont dit
en point de presse, auprès il va
peut-être s'en aller et peut-
être revenir à l'autre. On peut
se dire que c'est parce qu'il va
faire ce qu'il va s'en aller?
- Je voudrais que c'est associé,
je laisserai mes collègues
complétés, virus ont des phases
saisonnières. C'est connu. Par
contre les nouveaux virus peut
avoir des comportements
différents. Le H1N1 on avait vu
une vague présent alors qu'il
n'est pas habituellement
influenza et on a une accalmie
ensuite revenue à l'automne. Il
est possible, l'épreuve disait
que ce virus ralentisse un peu
sa course de transmission sont
présents, et qu'il revienne à
l'automne, mais est-ce qu'il va
appeler ça comme le disait le
docteur Weiss tantôt disparaît
adapter à la population humaine
et devenir un débit comme les
autres coronavirus qu'on a?
- D'autres éléments?
- On parle beaucoup de changer
les comportements en société
pour empêcher la propagation de
ce virus on a aussi, on doit
changer nos comportements sur
les réseaux sociaux, je ne à
tout le monde qui nous est dans
ce moment de faire vraiment
attention à ce que vous partagez
sur les réseaux sociaux. Vous
fiez-vous à des médias et des
sources gouvernementales, des
services de santé publique que
vous connaissez. De votre pays.
Et aussi des médias que vous
connaissez personnellement sur
le Web. Envoi des médias de
partout dans le monde, on ne les
connaît pas tout. Ne partagez
pas des articles de médias que
vous ne connaissez pas très
bien. Rester avec des sources
d'informations fiables que vous
connaissez, et auquel vous
faites confiance. Ne partagez
pas des publications qui m'aient
de l'avant des remèdes, des
photos ou des vidéos qui disent
: voici ce qui se passe a lieu
dans le monde possède de
détourner des photos ou des
vidéos comme ça. On a vu plein,
des photos et vidéos qui ont été
mal interprétées et qui cause
une panique généralisée. On fait
vraiment attention, on change
nos comportements sur les
réseaux sociaux pour empêcher la
propagation de la mauvaise
information sur le coronavirus,
commençant nos comportements
dans la société pour empêcher la
propagation du virus.
- Vous voulez ajouter quelque
chose?
- Je vous remercie, je les
dissoudra Baileys Mdame la
psychologue le faire aussi,
merci de passer ce message qu'on
a besoin de la collaboration des
gens. On n'a pas besoin de les
faire paniquer et de leur faire
faire des choses qui n'ont pas
d'allure.
- Un conseil pour les gens qui
paniquent?
- Je pense qu'il pourrait y
avoir une directive nationale
d'identifier des sources
crédibles. C'est quand même
difficile pour la population de
distinguer le bon grain de
l'ivraie. Quelqu'un qui apparaît
quelqu'un qui est vulnérable et
donc plus crédule. Donc c'est
quelqu'un qui va être porté
justement à croire un petit peu
tout ce qui se passe.
- Dernières rafales pour ce sont
des questions, Julie.
- Plusieurs parents de jeunes
enfants, dont je fais parti, sa
demande. Les écoles seront
fermées, qu'en est-il des
garderies?
À partir de cas en incubation le
virus dans notre corps peut-il
être dépisté à l'aide des tests?
Et enfin qu'en est-il de nos
téléphones cellulaires, cet
objet qu'on a toujours à la
main, qui n'est pas très propre
ou tout le contraire. Il était
le moyen de bien la nettoyer,
désinfecter parce que ça peut
devenir un objet de
transmission.
- Merci.
Garderies?
- On va évaluer. Il n'y a pas
d'élément actif mais si on ne
les met pas en garderies, on
peut déplacer le problème
ailleurs. Il y a des enjeux
comme ça. Et en garderies on
peut probablement appliquer des
mesures, des mesures d'hygiène
et de préventions qui sont
présentes. Mais ça demeure
encore une fois à évaluer selon
l'épidémie.
- La période maximale
d'incubation est de 14 jours en
moyenne ces cinq jours. On peut
donc en moyenne les symptômes se
manifestent alors votre voix
dépistée la maladie dans la
période de cinq jours.
- Les petits trucs pour le
nettoyage téléphonent
cellulaires, mais ça devrait
être élémentaire.
- C'est ce qu'on dit depuis tout
le temps, l'hygiène, étiquette
respiratoire, nettoyer les
objets inanimés.
- La peur rend les gens souvent
très individualistes. Si on veut
vraiment se protéger, il faut
avoir une vision collective
actuellement.
- Pour vous, le mot de la fin?
- Je pense qu'ensemble on va
pouvoir passer à travers cela.
Mais il va falloir que chacun
mette la main à la roue.
- Chaque petit geste est utile.
Se laver les mains est utile.
- Et ne pas serrer les mains.
- Je pense que c'est un projet
de société. Il faut qu'on soit
tous solidaires et qu'on
travaille dans le même sens, que
ce soit au niveau scientifique
mais surtout au niveau humain.ÀA
partir de là je pense qu'on va
essayer de limiter la courbe que
vous avez montre initialement et
la rendre la plus possible qu'on
ait moins d'impact sur la
société en général.
- Parce que vous allez, Docteur
Horacio Arruda, parler au
docteur des autres provinces.
Elle sidéra des défis
particuliers pour continuer à
parler avec Ottawa pour savoir
quelles mesures additionnelles
on peut prendre? On sent qu'au
Québec on est peut-être plus
proactif et rigoureux. Est-ce
que le mot rigoureux et exact?
Rappeler vos directives.
- Je vais faire attention avec
mes collègues. Chacun a ses
éléments mais on va bien entendu
quand ça concerne fédérale être
là pour mettre de l'influence.
On va aussi ne pas se faire
paralyser et agir qu'en ce
moment au Québec.
- Mais des conseils de mise en
isolement pour tous les gens qui
revient de voyage maintenant.
- On va devoir de discuter de
cela avec le fédéral.
- Quel que soit le pays, on doit
se mettre en isolement à partir
de maintenant.
Merci d'avoir participé à cette
émission spéciale qui était
présents pour informer le
public. Demain, à l'émission,
encore une émission de deux
heures mais je vous rappelle
quand même que toutes les écoles
sont fermées en Ontario demain,
toujours pas de directives de
Québec concernant les écoles
mais avec ce qu'on a entendu ce
soir et que je serais à l'écoute
de 24 à 60 demain, on aura peut-
être des informations de ce
côté. Plusieurs commissions
scolaires ont annoncé qu'elles
seront fermées demain.
Des collèges privés également.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission, nous étions là pour
vous informer, répondre à cet
appel au calme et à la
solidarité, et à la conviction
qu'il faut bien s'informer.
Cette pour ce soir. Rester à
l'antenne pour le Téléjournal
avec Céline Galipeau.
À demain, 19 heures, pour une
émission de deux heures encore
une fois et vos questions.
Sous-titrage : SRC 2020